qu'est-ce que vous allez lui dire au
ministre on veut le retrait du projet de
vaquer pour retrouver les premiers pas
de David Assouline en politique il faut
remonter jusqu'à sa tendre jeunesse au
lycée puis à l'université sépare le
syndicalisme que le jeune étudiant se
lance dans la bataille les centaines de
milliers d'étudiants
ils sont montés de toute la France n'ont
rien obtenu de plus
donc les centaines de milliers
d'étudiants
qui ont payé parfois cher leur voyage
comme ceux de Marseille
n'ont pas été écoutés quand on est sorti
et qu'on traversait les cordons de
policiers sur la place des Invalides
pour rejoindre les centaines de milliers
de manifestants qui attendaient notre
compte rendu et bien tout de suite même
sur le camion
sono sur lequel j'étais pour parler
c'était des tiers de Grenade et attires
tendus sur la foule et sur le camion
antiracisme et lutte contre l'extrême
droite font l'essence de son engagement
quand dans le milieu des années 80 il
participe à la marche des beurres ou aux
manifestations contre le projet de loi
de vaquer qui mèneront à la mort de
Malik Oussekine c'est quelque chose qui
qui m'a marqué parce que la
responsabilité d'un mouvement aussi
massif
qui a fait chancelet le gouvernement est
probablement qui a fait très bûcher
Jacques Chirac était premier à être
président de la République en 88
qui n'a pas été probablement parce que
il s'est mis la jeunesse ado à ce
moment-là
la violence mais c'était des violences
policières très fortes qui ont abouti à
cette mort c'est quelque chose qui m'a
tout de suite
fait conjuguer
engagement
détermination mais aussi responsabilité
longtemps adhérent à la Ligue
révolutionnaire communiste David
Assouline fait le pari de suivre Pierre
Juquin pour sa première campagne
présidentielle puis du rouge Le Parisien
viro-rose à l'approche des élections
municipales de 1995 et contribue à la
bonne percée des socialistes dans la
capitale si la ville reste à droite la
gauche obtient si mairies
d'arrondissement les prémices d'un long
règne à venir
on est venu me chercher en 95 dans le
20e
c'était à l'époque le 20 sur 20 de la
droite 20 arrondissements sur 20 était
avec Jacques Chirac et avec la droite et
dans le 20e arrondissement comme dans
plusieurs quartiers populaires
on sentait que c'était plus tellement
accepté et qui avait un
mouvement associatif très fort
et une gauche qui était prête à
comprendre
les attentes des Parisiens et dans ces
quartiers populaires en 2001 c'est
l'alternance à l'hôtel de ville dans le
sillage de Bertrand Delanoë Davida
souligne devient adjoint au maire chargé
de la vie étudiante et s'investit
notamment sur les hébergements parce
qu'on me disait il y a pas peut pas
construire à Paris il y a pas d'endroit
donc
c'est dense il y a le privé et donc je
prenais ma bagnole et puis je chaque
fois que je voyais dans creuse
je j'appelais les services mais moi j'ai
vu que bon etc c'est comme ça que je
bossais on en a construit beaucoup 4000
en 3 ans je crois des attributions qu'il
gardera jusqu'en 2004 et son entrée au
Sénat tout le monde me dit tu vas t'en
croûter attention etc
cette tension là sera encore plus forte
et c'est un challenge que que je me
donne à moi-même j'avais une image d'une
chambre
[Musique]
et je m'interrogeais sur son utilité
réelle je suis obligé de vous dire après
tout ce cheminement ce que j'en pense
aujourd'hui
j'ai compris que cette chambre était
utile et nécessaire
parce que si elle le voulait elle
pouvait être la vraie garantie de la
séparation des pouvoirs et d'une
délibération parlementaire
libre et non dictée par l'exécutif alors
que le socialiste découvre le travail de
parlementaire au sein de son parti il
choisit son camp et fonde aux côtés de
Vincent Peillon de Benoît Hamon et
d'Arnaud Montebourg le Nouveau Parti
socialiste plus tard c'est derrière
Ségolène Royal que le militant parisien
se range en vue de l'élection
présidentielle à l'époque elle a mis un
coup de pied dans la fourmilière
avec desirs d'avenir il y avait des
dizaines de milliers de gens qui
n'étaient pas dans les partis qui
venaient avec enthousiasme quand on
arrive avec ces voyelles royales dans un
quartier populaire c'était presque
l'émeubles de l'enthousiasme dans le
même temps au Palais du Luxembourg les
luparisiens se prend de passion pour des
sujets tels que l'audiovisuel
aujourd'hui ministre vous engagez-vous à
agir pour que le service public au moins
reste un lieu où la diversité
d'indépendance soit garantie et pas
celui où on aime d'abord et toujours le
président Sarkozy l'indépendance de la
presqu'île en fera son cheval de
bataille dès 2009 avec une proposition
de loi conjointe avec le député
socialiste Patrick Bloch contre la
concentration des médias alors certains
disent oui mais bon vous avez des
milliardaires ils s'engère pas
parce qu'ils sont gentils mais s'ils
étaient méchants un domaine qui le
défendra bec et oncle à l'occasion d'une
commission d'enquête face au
Tout-Puissant Vincent Bolloré je n'ai
pas le pouvoir de nommer qui que ce soit
l'intérieur des chaînes et voilà que
Bolloré arrive
démocrate chrétien il y a moins d'une
dizaine d'années passées à la à
l'extrême droite
qui pensent avoir une mission
civilisatrice qui pense que
ce grand remplacement menace la vieille
France
chrétienne qui est devenue sa cause
et voilà qui met tout ça au service de
cette idéologie et on se rend compte
qu'on peut se réveiller avec la gueule
de bois parce que je le répète ça c'est
la bataille culturelle
c'est comme ça que sera droite peut
arriver au pouvoir une fonction de
contrôle que l'intéressé prend au mot
son dernier combat sur les bancs de
l'hémicycle David Assouline le même
début 2023 contre la réforme des
retraites
un combat coordonné pendant une dizaine
de jours entre les différentes
composantes de la gauche nous notre
stratégie va être très combatif en écho
avec le mouvement syndical avec cette
mobilisation qui convainc une majorité
de Français jusqu'à présent mais en même
temps en jouant notre rôle de
parlementaire avec au bout un constat
d'échec être opposant je l'ai été
quasiment tout le temps dans cette
hémicycle d'abord parce que la majorité
à part trois ans que j'ai vécu et de
droite mais aussi vis-à-vis du pouvoir
à part sous le quinquennat de François
Hollande
mais justement je me suis dit j'ai
attendu ce moment où la gauche allait
gagner et finalement
le fonctionnement
des pouvoirs sous la Cinquième
République et a toujours été même pour
la gauche de tenir très peu compte
du Parlement et donc beaucoup
d'insatisfaction même quand le pouvoir
est de ton bord politique après 19 ans
au Palais du Luxembourg et près de 50
ans d'engagement le socialiste parisien
s'apprête à rendre l'écharpe mais garde
un œil à Visé sur cette vie politique
qui l'anime encore c'est clair
qu'après l'expérience Macron
[Musique]
s'il y a pas la gauche en capacité de
gagner c'est l'extrême droite qui sera
au pouvoir alors je répète sur le plan
politique il faut une autre offre
attractive pour l'empêcher sinon
inéluctuellement ça sera elle s'il rend
les clés de son casier et de son bureau
rue de Vaugirard l'ancien élu du 20ème
ne sera jamais bien loin il continuera
d'arpenter les rues de la capitale qui
un jour lui ont donné la fièvre de la
politique les jeunes sont prêts
mais il faut que l'offre politique
Vienne
répondre et à leur audace et à leurs
aspirations donc l'optimisme c'est que
je pense que que
il y a beaucoup de talents et
de force dans la nouvelle génération
et de liberté de liberté dans leur tête
plus que les générations d'avant
[Musique]